[Music]
hmm
all right what's up mkbhd here
so homepod mini
this little guy right here
it's out
a surprising amount of you guys have
been asking about it i say surprising
because the original homepod was not
exactly a smash hit it was a 350 dollar
siri enabled smart speaker
that sounded amazing but didn't really
do a whole lot so yeah in my review i
literally called it the dumbest smart
speaker
because it was but now this homepod mini
kind of flips the script as far as what
you would expect and priorities for
someone looking for a little smart
speaker like this i'm actually going to
talk about sound quality last because i
think it's like one of the last things
you're actually looking for and
expecting when you're buying a smaller
smart speaker like this
so let's talk about my week with the
homepod mini so first of all the design
of the homepod mini i think is pretty
nice honestly this is about as good as a
compact smart speaker can look without a
real functional display it's only about
three inches tall it's got this mesh
fabric all the way around the animations
that play while you're using that little
circular top display are pretty neat
they go all the way to the edges of the
circular display
and the thing still feels premium when
you touch it if you ever do but there
are some things that feel less elegant
about this one in particular
so one i have the black one it has a
black plastic top and if you touch this
black plastic to change the volume or
change songs or anything like that you
instantly leave fingerprints so if you
plan on doing that maybe get the white
one so it doesn't look like cheap
fingerprinty plastic quite as fast and
then two it still has a permanently
attached braided power cable that comes
out the back but now it terminates in a
usbc port and then it actually does come
with in the box the apple standard 20
watt usbc power brick this white one
it's crazy we actually have to specify
that it comes with a power brick now but
yes thankfully it does
but i also think it looks kind of odd
with the black cable and then the white
brick but really my complaint is we all
know this thing is going to plug in
behind a dresser or a nightstand or in a
corner somewhere i think it would have
been nice if it were like a 90 degree
plug or something smaller like we've
seen in some other smart speakers but
it's not so that part feels kind of
inelegant too but overall i'm just going
to say i think homepod mini is still a
great design
for something without a screen i still
prefer smart speakers with screens but
this one doesn't look weird in a kitchen
or in a bedroom or anywhere else in a
house it's small it's unobtrusive this
is how a mini speaker should be so then
the reason people are buying these
cheaper
smaller smart speakers is just as the
entry point to turning your home into a
smart home basically a lot of people's
first time doing that
and in theory a siri enabled speaker
should be the ideal place to start so my
take is this for homepod mini the more
apple things that you use
the deeper you are in apple world
the better
this thing is so okay if you don't use
that many apple services but you just
have an iphone let's say you set this
thing up and you can talk to siri and
we've all seen the gradual improvements
on siri over time she knows more facts
now you know she knows how tall some
more buildings are you can ask her to do
more things you can listen to the news
or get the weather or all the classic
stuff like that hey siri tell me a joke
i saw a movie about how ships are put
together
it was riveting
hey siri tell me a good joke
what does it cost to hire a spy
i could tell you but then i'd have to
bill you
siri can do timers and yes she can do
more than one timer at once despite not
having a functional screen to keep track
of them all and of course when your
iphone is on the same wi-fi network you
can send and receive texts or start
phone calls and it glows green while
it's doing that so that's already pretty
convenient but if you just add
also apple music
to the things from apple that you use
suddenly homepod becomes a lot more
useful so now you can ask siri for songs
or playlists or ask what song is playing
and she'll tell you what it is but the
best feature the most impressive
actually from the u1 chip and the new
iphones is this beam feature all you
have to do is touch your iphone to the
homepod in just the right spot on the
front or the back and it pretty much
instantly beams whatever music you're
playing to the speaker and when the
speaker's playing music you can touch
them and it like snatches the music back
to playing from the phone
it's pretty sweet it takes a few tries
to maybe get it just right to press it
in the right spot but once you find it
it's a sweet demo and the fact that it
works so well and so quickly is the most
impressive part to me
[Music]
it's pretty quick but also side note
this only works with other
devices that are in your family or on
your network already so if you in theory
had a friend come over i think it would
be cool
if they could put their phone up against
the speaker and it would like give them
a link to or just tell you
what song is playing
that's like a free feature suggestion
apple feel free to use that that would
be cool but still even on top of that if
you use apple music the multi-room
listening experience is so easy on the
drop down of the iphone i'm insanely
jealous of how quickly and easily you
can create a stereo pair or just light
up every speaker you have at once with
the same music so if you use apple music
and you have two home pods it's really
easy to just play the same song on both
you can also just say hey
assistant play this everywhere and it'll
just light up everything it's fast and
then there is also pandora support for
all these features as well so if you use
pandora for your music or podcasts you
can do all this beaming and all this
stuff as well but there seems to be a
little bit more of a delay like a second
and a half delay if you're using pandora
but it works so natural question because
we didn't see it at launch what about
spotify of course i use spotify for all
my music
and the answer is apparently it's
potentially coming soon and it's up to
spotify
so
we saw spotify support come to the apple
watch i believe they could be working on
it i hope to see it soon fingers crossed
because again just beaming it around
easy multi-speaker support all that
stuff is sweet so then if you keep
adding apple stuff if you use apple
podcasts you can ask siri or homepod to
start playing your podcast or picking up
where you left off if you use an apple
tv later this year you'll be able to use
one or a pair of homepod minis in stereo
for dolby atmos quality sound you can
use siri to ask for directions somewhere
it'll automatically drop the results in
apple maps on your iphone you can ask it
to take notes it'll drop it in the notes
app in your iphone and it can read from
your calendar if you use apple's
calendar stuff too and then there's like
this final boss mode galaxy brain super
plugged into the ecosystem feature
where if you have an entire family of
people who all use apple devices at the
same time
then you can talk to them all at once
through the intercom feature so you can
speak a message to siri and it'll just
light up everyone's apple watches and
iphones and every other homepod in the
whole house
so you can say hey siri intercom what's
good everybody
[Music]
what's good everybody
there's a
there's a homepod over there so play the
message
worked pretty fast so the moral of the
story is the more plugged in you are to
apple stuff and the more apple services
and devices you use the better homepod
is for you and then if you want to get
started with a smart home you have to
get home kit enabled accessories and
then you slowly start to build it up
from there but i think that's where it's
smart to start peeking over the walls of
that garden a little bit and looking at
the competition and compatibility
because if that's really your only goal
is to get into the smart home game
amazon's alexa products have a zillion
more choices and all sorts of different
sizes and form factors
some with screens and most importantly
by far the most compatibility with smart
home stuff and there's something like a
hundred thousand alexa skills and then
in second place is google home and all
that smart home ecosystem and then so in
like a distant third place
just as far as overall compatibility you
have apple stuff with home kit but what
i will say is this guy definitely sounds
massively better than any of the other
speakers i just talked about like that's
how homepod kind of started with the
original homepod focused on sound
quality this one it's obviously much
smaller so you're not expecting nearly
as much sound
and it also has less drivers but it's
still for something three inches tall
gives you a lot of audio and there's a
pretty good amount of bass too and
clarity at all volume levels where
others like google home mini and alexa
dot which are similar in size anyway
definitely sound much worse at those
higher volumes so this homepod is
getting louder and sounding better and
the sound is also roughly even from all
directions so no matter where you are in
a room it's going to sound pretty much
the same
unlike some of the more directional
setups like from google and from amazon
and on top of that they've got the s5
chip in here which they say is analyzing
the music you're playing 180 times per
second and applying complex tuning
algorithms to make sure your music
sounds its best now i don't know how
much of a difference that makes you
can't turn it on or off it's just kind
of the way it sounds and it sounds fine
sounds really good
but if that's something you're focused
on if that's something you care about is
still sound quality
and something really small
this is great for that putting a pair of
them in stereo is kind of like this
room-filling
sound it's really good so at the end of
the day the 99 question
is homepod mini actually good is it
actually worth it
so here's how i'd answer that
if it's a good deal you're after
well you could get three google home
minis for the same price and put them in
three different rooms to get you started
so it's not the best deal
if it's the best compatibility you're
after for starting off your smart home
well amazon's alexa dot is around the
same price if not less you can get a
more expensive one but that's going to
be dramatically more compatible with way
more smart home stuff to start
so it's not the most compatible
and if it's just the best assistant
you're after well you could look to
either google or amazon to give you a
better assistant than siri i still think
that's true
but if it's
that seamless experience with the apple
ecosystem and sound quality that you're
after
well
that's when you get the homepod
so that's been it
thanks for watching and i'll catch you
guys very soon in the next one
peace